وقد قال الرئيس الاوكراني يفردومينوزنسكي
يعقب عودته من واشنطن حيث حصل على تعهدات
بدعم نوعين امريكيه قال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقاتل من اجل تحقيق النصر في
مواجهه الغزو الروسي وفي لقاء مع سفره
اوكرانيا في الخارج توقع زيلانسكي زياده
الهجمه الروسيه في موسم الاعياد
المقبل
تحرير ارضنا وحمايه شعبنا واستعاده بلادنا
بعد الضربات الروسيه هذه هي خطوات
الانتصار الاوكراني الذي نقترب منه خطوه
بخطوه اننا نرى افاقا للتقدم على الجبهات
ونستعد لمختلف افعال الدوله الارهابيه
وانارانياتها والسلام عليكم
مستوى جديد في السياسه الخارجيه لمواجهته
حالات الطوارئ
وكاله المعونه الدوليه الاخرانيه التي
ستوسع جغرافيه نفود الاخرانيه على حد
وصفحه
السلام عليكم
طوال السنه لا يحق لنا الحصول على عطله
نهايه الاسبوع وليس لدينا الحق في الراحه
والعطله وليس لدينا الحق في يوم عمل مدته
ثمان ساعات علينا جميعا اننا ما اقل من
العدو ونفكر اكثر منه و نتواصل مع العالم
بشكل افضل من الضروري رفع قدره اوكرانيا
الى مستوى جديد في السياسه الخارجيه
لحالات الطوارئ يجب ان يشعر الجميع
بوجودنا ويهتم بمساعدتنا ونستعد الان
لانشائي وكاله المعونه الدوليه الاوكرانيه
التي ستوسع جغرافيه
وتخلق خطوط اضافيه للتعاون مع الشركاء